p
bonjour et bienvenue dans cette émission
nous allons traiter aujourd'hui jean
baptiste de la française d'avant ce
bonjour stéphane bonjour à tous ou une
variante intéressante de la défense
française il y en a beaucoup
là c'est là
variante qu'on choisit quand on veut
laisser le centre fermé on l'a fait
attention en fait et on avance le pion
pour enfermer le faux case blanche
alors avant de voir justement ce que
c'est que cette vente précédemment on
peut citer quelques grand port quai qui
jouent cette cette variante alors les
plus connus on peut en publicité se sont
chiffrés gris tchouk surtout qui est un
très bon spécialiste de la française
d'avant sachant qu'elle a été employée
par de très nombreux joueurs du top
mondial spécialiste avec les blancs ça
veut dire que c'est aussi une variante
pour les grands attaquants parce que je
suis référé choque ce sont de grands
attaquants
ce sont des joueurs qui aiment beaucoup
l'initiative c'est vrai que c'est basé
sur un contrôle fort du centre voilà
donc c'est une variante intéressante
pour ceux qui souhaitent développer de
table sur les aime alors on va voir ça
tout de suite
avec cet échiquier et ça se caractérise
cette française d' avance par les coûts
donc que 4 aussi jean baptiste assez
caractéristique de la barrière est
français c'est la variante française oui
des cards théâtre donc des cinq des cinq
essais l'idée de 6 on veut essayer
d'égaliser les forces au centre après un
échange
sur les chances du cadre prend des 5e 6e
rang des saints qui on a le même nombre
de pions au sens voilà et la période
d'avant ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui il ya
d'autres variantes française on va
passer vraiment complètement là dessus
c'est on va s'occuper dans cette leçon
uniquement de la vente d'avant ce qu'ils
vont très belles armes à connaître des
deux côtés puisque actuellement autant
avec les blancs cabinet noir
elle peut être très très courante c'est
une variante qui a une logique en plus
ça le coup eux 5
eh bien on est en train de faire
réaliser aux noirs que on a enterré leur
fausser 8
voilà c'est un fou s'est vite ici il est
bloqué tout de suite par le pion aux 6
on a pris aussi un petit avantage des
espaces avec confiance un bien placé
dans le camp noir on bouchonne ici cette
phalange de pions voilà c'est
l'inconvénient principal quand même de
la défense française c'est la place que
va tenir le fou s'est vite dans la
partie e 5
même si ça c'est d'la attention
au moins ça mérite dans tes veines fou
alors il ya un petit inconvénient quand
même à secouer 5 et on va le voir avec
le couloir suivant c'est que maintenant
les noirs ont le sont renseignés sur la
forme que les blancs ont donné à leurs
chaînes de pions donc ils vont attaquer
la chaîne de pion à la base
à la base tout ça là bas donc là on a
une minichaîne à lorient à la base ou à
la tête et comme on veut en attaque
voilà ici c'est à la base avec des
quatre donc pour consolider le centre
les blancs jouent le coup le plus
naturel stéphane à savoir la c3 c3 sont
vraiment normal il faut le font pas ils
à le faire donc là on se protège mon
gars de ces entretiens la drôme vers le
centre on s'assied cacher la défense
française celui social un thème un souci
c'est qu'on va retrouver dans toute la
défense française
voilà alors après soit on sort le
cavalier c6 tout de suite soit les noirs
qui commence déjà à regretter d'avoir
intérieur fou et c'est peut-être de le
sortir alors comment est ce qu'on peut
faire pour sortir avec un moyen assez
artificiel on peut peut-être regarder
stéphane nature d'un v6 d'un v6 avec
l'idée alors d'abord un jeu rajoute de
la pression sur tout à fait voilà dame
est toujours bien placée en b 600 g sur
la case normal de la défense françois là
donc ça il faut bien connaître et le
thème des noirs que veulent faire venir
si le couffo 17 suivi de forme et ça
pourrait changer difficilement lutter
contre en soutien à ses vues blanc on
peut pas on peut pas mais c'est pas très
grave pour les blancs parce que ça passe
a perdu temps c'est un peu lent ça perd
du temps donc les blancs ont des
arguments
alors on va cavalière 317 voilà l'ol en
fout d'eux on se développe alors on se
développe quand même c'est à dire que on
n'a pas cru utile aussi a parfois c'est
le problème que là où il faut jouer il
faut des coûts de développement de nos
enseignes a pas de problème c'est
prendre les quatre points d'écart on est
effondré sans qu'il fait mais ça va ça y
est on va échanger avec les noirs le
goût est sous contrôle fois deux voies
la ceo paul peu une séparation peut-être
un petit peu douloureuse pour les blancs
parce que ce foot là se lance dans la
vente d' avance souvent un fou d'attac
en revanche on a quand même des
décompensations qui sont pas
négligeables c'est à dire sur le coup
cavaliers c3 paralysante voilà on va pas
prendre vis évidemment nous mêmes non
non c'est mieux de
en sortir encore une pièce
supplémentaire c'est ça notre
compensation c'est à dire qu'on va voilà
du plan de développement qui va nous
servir comme on va le voir dans la suite
que l'on vous propose donc franco belge
avec amélie prend pas ce que ce cavalier
on va le recycler en fait
on en profite en fait pour faire balader
ce cavalier de ce côté on semble
profiter de le côté et oui voilà on va
essayer d à s'attaquer aux plans g7 et
via f4 5,6 des choses comme ça donc il
faut vraiment bien connaître et blanc ce
qui se passe là parce que ce plan quand
même plante dangereux stratégiquement
c'est en belgique - on a échangé le
meilleur fout des blancs voilà si on
réagit pas de manière vigoureuse et bien
on va se retrouver avec un fou en c1 pas
terrible alors pourquoi il est pas
terrible ce foot place blanche jean
baptiste et bien tout simplement on dit
qu'il est mauvais parce qu'il est soit
la couleur des pions bloqués voilà ces
pionnières qui fait doublon c'est
inception contrôler les cases noires et
se font déjà du mal à naviguer contre
alors que l'avocate blanche étaient
complémentaires donc c'était le bal en
blanc chaud arrivé à surfer en milieu
des pions ce qui semble être une
mauvaise affaire peuvent être
transformés par le gain de temps donc il
faut se dépêcher aussi avec les blancs
contre carillo cette petit rock cavalli
c6 ça c'est un plan avec les blancs
parce que ces cavaliers sont pouvait pas
sentir h67 coislin qu'on vous prend et
ce câble une fois en sept fallait
trouver une case donc les noirs préfère
le mettre en c6 la tourbe est un donc à
tomber à je protège champions alors
c'est beaucoup et c'est pour libérer le
fou et je se libérer le fonds qui
peuvent venir sur la case sur la case d3
ou ailleurs à cinq cavaliers de kalana
la part des blancs servat c'est là qu'on
rentre déjà dans le plan voilà on
commence à envahir un petit peu les
droits on a un centre qui est stabilisé
alors c'est vrai de notre foot cate
blanchet a disparu mais en tout cas avec
cavaliers f4 on a on commence à ramener
des pièces vraiment une manière très
bonne assante sur le sol est le roi on
croyait alors qu'elle est née cette
foule droit voilà donc ligne de tomber
un complexe de développement complète le
développement fawcett est maintenant va
laisser passer la dame hélas hélas le
coupler cette variante cavaliers des
deux car il est donc ça c'est le conclut
qu'il faut connaître à la on enlève une
défense aux pions des quatre mais on
laisse passer la dame
c'est à dire qu'ici la menace qu'on veut
exécuter avec les lancers de venir en g4
ici d'hameçons car voilà on va attaquer
le plan g7 et en même temps le ku'damm
g4 quand même jette un oeil sur le pion
des 4 1 et 4 et là mais là on simplifie
ce pion et le problème c'est que les
normes pas trop le choix c'est ça qui
font prendre ce qu'ils ont alors ils
peuvent attendre un peu avant de prendre
peut-être en tout cas tout ou tard il
faudra le faire dans la partie on a
intercalé à 4 oui avec l'erreur ce
serait le petit rock
ouais ce serait effectivement un petit
peu dangereux quand même en imaginant le
petit rock il faut commencer à ramener
la dame comme on l'avait probablement
d'alger 4 avec la menace simple car il
est acheté un euro il ya beaucoup de
pièces détachées et on peut ramener le
cavalier d2 en f3 pour la preuve qu'il a
fait son boulot on pourra jouer
peut-être h4 si besoin
ça ça risque d'être très dangereux dans
la seine bonne position pour les blancs
dentition en attaque
voilà donc voilà comment il faut jouer
cette variante c'est ce qu'on sait ce
qu'on préconise enfin c'est de jouer ce
plan ne pas hésiter donc de le caler c3
qui reprend le fou ici en deux avions
f406 pression sur les droits et ensuite
on va pas hésiter à jour le plus calme
de pour libérer la dame aussi sur le roi
donc pression très rapide
on va profiter de la développement pour
mettre la pression sur la langue non
rentables du temps pour retourner en
fougasse blanche on en profite en
activant vite les pièces sur les
endroits sensibles
alors ça c'est simplement c'est une
option qu'on lui doit s'élancer vers en
avant soirée donc on va voir maintenant
une autre option bien sûr l'asie
alors après le coup ces trois donc ici
au lieu de jouer le coup d'un v6 voilà
qui était cette idée là alors on ne
relevait plus tard mais disons qu'on va
commencer par ce coup k et ses six
blessés six donc là on dit adieu pour le
noir ce plan un fou 17 fou mais simple
puisque on a mis le cavalier sur les sur
le trajet est donc ça va pas du tout
être le même le même thème le traitement
doit être différent absolument
cavalier à 3 donc je surprotège
évidemment le pion des cats
alors maintenant tu donnes des fils donc
la dame mais si ce qui est logique
voilà d'un v6 c'est logique puisque l'on
met encore une pression sur le plan des
cats qui est le petit talon d'achille
des blancs dans cette variante est bien
protégé puisque il a trois défenseurs
voilà alors qu'en trois défenses la clé
je dirais dans cette dans cette
ouverture soit c'est de le surprotéger
soit c'est un sacrifice soit celle de
données voila voila contre d'activité
alors on va regarder quoi d'abord le
sacrifice le sacrifice alors le
sacrifice on peut jouer effectivement le
risque que les noirs ne sont pas obligés
d'accepter d'ailleurs mais dans ces cas
là le foie en désespoir est très bien
placé superbe
c'est un très bon fou puisqu'il horn ya
des deux côtés
et il est derrière la couleur opposée
c'est un superbe fou donc les noirs ont
atterri dans la pièce contrecarrer cette
pièce ça s'appelle comment se nomme vite
c'est le gros bill milner barry milner
barry voilà un nom un peu compliqué
alors ici puis on prend des quatre qui
on prend les quatre alors tout de suite
petit piège c'est que les noirs ne
peuvent pas jouer le coup pourtant
évident en cavale et prend des quatre
puisqu'après câblée prendre cavaliers on
se dit mais oui non mais les noirs
prennent en et 4 oui mais en fait non
pourquoi parce que tout simplement fou
dès cet échec une mauvaise nouvelle
mauvaise nouvelle et la dame ait perdu
puisqu'il va falloir défendre les
chèques par exemple par wade 8 et
d'improbables gagne damned
nonaka découverte sais que c'est pénible
tout petit peu fini mais extrêmement
violent tout dire même donc après c'est
prendre les quatre il faut d'abord jouer
avec tellement lecouffe ou 17
voilà qui en brèche éviter la découverte
à découvrir dans ce cas là les blancs
ont pas de moyens efficaces afin de
protéger des cadres de toute façon
puisque le fou des trois déjà empêche la
dame de protéger s'ils ont reculé le
foudre et du temps ça serait vraiment
pas une bonne nouvelle aussi les
feuilles les cavaliers p4 voilà résumé
tôt je vous le donne et donc on le donne
avec petit rock et voilà l'idée c'est
caprica va lui prendre cali cabaye prend
dame prend des quatre on joue le simple
qui a blessé trois avec la menace
développement avant tout cas pas des
dessins voilà on donne le deuxième pion
aux scènes qui vont revoir qu'on va la
récupérer très vite ce pion de me
prendre cinq tours 1 dolby vite je
trouve à l'est en bibitte sinon c'est
trop dangereux de rester au centre et là
tout simplement récupère ici le pion
voilà donc quelques jours ap londres -
pour les blancs on hamm est le seul qui
ont le moins mais une belle position
puisque très dynamique très open alors
en général et noir poursuivre par le
coup mais voilà ça c'est la théorie
effectivement dame est fou attaque quand
même le bon ordre en un petit peu et sur
damas un bon jour en général dames h5
qui cloue le pion à vii
à noter que le pion aux six aussi et
plouay sur la tour ce qui protège
indirectement le cavalier dessin par
exemple sur le coup qu'on fout c'est si
ce qui serait une erreur tout simplement
les blancs peuvent vite pourquoi aussi
c'est possible voilà puisque le pion ne
peut pas reprendre la torah cause
de l'échec de la dame donc c'est pas un
bon coup pour ces six donc en général et
noir vont plutôt jouer le coup droit et
fuite ici et donc ceux des rocs
oui mais bon il était un peu trop sous
pression entre clans cloud et voilà donc
ils préfèrent mettre le roi plus ou
moins à l'abri je dirais voilà le
cavalier maintenant est attaqué et où là
il faut le rapatrier on a eu peu de
jouer cavalier 3 on peut envisager
cavaliers ou trois ans si oui alors
voilà qu'elle c3 puis je pense qu'on
peut s'arrêter pour ses variantes
tout à fait on jauge est juste un coup
d'oeil pour essayer de l'évaluer on a
sacrifié un pion voilà donc les forces
en présence c'est bien les uns les noirs
ont un pion plus donc grâce à ses côtés
positifs
le problème c'est qu'ils ont un roi en
fuite est encore un léger retard de
développement dont c'est une partie où
chacun des deux camps va essayer de
prouver qu'il a eu raison bien sûr
qu'ils vont donc là pour les blancs les
attaquants vont aimer cette position un
jeu vous tranquillement une belle
attaque avec un pion de moins mais on
voit des rockets les matérialistes ont
préféré les noirs pour la matérialiste
et les joueurs à long terme qui vient
jouer les finales vont essayer de tenir
jusqu'à la finale et de remporter en gnl
avec un point de plus de tout ce qui
arrive et après il faut y arriver bien
sûr comme dit l'autre avant les finales
les dieux en place et le mieux donc à
bf3 fou 17
voilà le lyonnais malheureusement la vie
sort d'anne decis oui pardon son ami
john zeng b6 donc au lieu de donner le
pion comment est ce qu'on fait pour le
surprotéger donc au lieu de jouer les
fous des trois ici voilà ça option bien
sûr protéger ceux qui ont des quatre
parce qu'il a un souci si on est quatre
les noirs vont prendre des 4 et après
ils vont menacer de jouer thériault 7 et
cavaliers pts 5
voilà donc pour ça il va falloir sion
fait d absolument notre fou de cases
noires voilà bien le foot cases noires
vous rendrez compte qu'il a beaucoup de
mal à sortir à cause du plan b de holler
voilà donc ça c'est un petit problème
alors que feront les blancs vont s'en
débarrasser eh bien on joue à trois
voilà donc ça c'est un point clé à jouer
ici un couple et si vraiment surjoue pas
la variante avec 10,3 il faut jouer à
trois avec l'idée avec l'idée de jouer
des cadres et 4 pour se débarrasser de
la faiblesse en b2
j'aime faire pression sur ces cinq
forcer son pion à prendre une décision
on prend là on va avoir fait valoir à
prendre une décision de relancer 5 et
ensuite on met le fou en b2 pour
surprotéger la surprotection le principe
de ninkovic à ne pas confondre avec
passivité et la surprotection s'est
consolidée à tout prix notre seul point
faible pour empêcher leurs adversaires
d'avoir du jeu notre adversaire n'a plus
ce jeu il a besoin de jouer des mauvais
coups voilà donc la surprotection c'est
un principe simple il faut bien
différencier de la passivité
alors si les noirs jouant cavalier 6 on
peut continuer avec b 4 b 4 voilà et là
on espère qu'on prend une décision en
général tandis qu'à briser ou de l'autre
c'est pareil les prix et puis tout
simplement on va pouvoir jouer le fou en
d2 le fonds en b2 tranquillement
d'autrefois de petit rock cavaliers des
deux cavaliers b3 canal 3 et on va venir
sur la belle case c5 et après une fois
qu'on a de la poterie et tout ça deux
pièces peuvent repartir de plus belle
mais sur un jeu tour cn en elle-même que
l'on sait on a un jeu classique sur la
fournaise ici donc alors alors peut-être
sur aa3 on peut mentionner quand même
une autre option qui est su allier jouer
au lieu de cavaliers achi c'est les
coûts c4 du coup c'est catherine qui
essayent de profiter de
l'affaiblissement en b3 et qui empêche
b4 myers à en faire encore un peu plus
le fou c'est 8 alors à noter évidemment
sur b4 simplement le rappeler si à la
prison personne la prise en passant
puisqu'on peut prendre le pion magath en
passant ici le tueur a bougé de deux
cases on peut encore faire comme s'il
n'avait bougé que d'une seule case seul
cas aux échecs nous prend une pièce
ailleurs que sur sa case voilà cette
règle un petit peu étrange mais donne un
peu de charme
exactement donc ici alors là maintenant
que les noirs décidé de fermer le centre
eh bien on va attaquer à l'ale avec f4
f5 cavaliers de la poussée d'abord on se
développe et se développe on va voir la
suite
donc ici par exemple ou du seul essai
voilà donc on n'est pas fort important
vous regardez
l'idée est roi voilà j'ai trois
cavaliers à 5 h 4 voilà alors l'idée
c'est de mettre le fou en h3 on va
mettre le fond h3 parce qu'on a visé
cette case et puis ensuite on retire à
cavalier on jouera f4 f5 et henri
cavallier f4 et f5 éventuellement g46
fou même quand le centre est fermé dans
les ouvertures on peut se permettre ce
genre de fantaisie à savoir les coûts de
pions sur les ailes puisque le le centre
ne va pas sauver tout de suite notamment
jean mathis parce qu'ici faut pas
oublier que le point crucial de cette
variante voilà la colonne point de
vertébrale de cette cette position c'est
cette ces deux chaînes de pions qui se
regardent et qui du coup bloquent le
centre et dont elle permettre de jouer à
elle s'en ressent trop haut sans prendre
de risques voilà c'est ça on peut se le
permettre
voilà il faut simplement avoir un oeil
sur d'éventuelles sacrifice de pièces
ont ça en train de saper argonautes
toujours il faut un petit peu regardé
les puissants le centre de regroupement
des quatre ne viendra n'aura pas donc
on revient sur wii on revient sur la
variante avec fu 17 qu'elle y avait
trois fous 17 alors cavalière 3 alors
d'avoir dans les variations d'un v6 les
deux mares donc alors on peut jouer donc
derrière à 3 on le voit on peut jouer
les 3 et là on va voir une autre
possibilité d'un coup d'un seul coup des
sachets de suite également très joué et
alors là l'idée on a c'est toujours le
même coup mais pas dans le même en or we
say l'écoutent ressemblent toutes façons
ce soit un ordre ou un autre les coups
se ressemblent
à norma invité dans cette partie qu'on a
choisi qui on a pas dit encore on a
choisi un pur spécialiste de la bande
annonce pour vous montrer cette variante
c'est alexei shirov voilà qui il a joué
très longtemps cette variante de manière
égale avec kbc 3 d'ailleurs mais il aime
bien la varende avance on peut également
citer gritche ou par exemple comme un
grand spécialiste de la varende avance
et surtout 17 alors il a une idée qui
n'est pas une idée qui lui appartient
mais notre ami shirov est un est un fin
connaisseur des produits des grands
principes denisot vite chez toi qui l'a
habillé de surprotection dupiol des 4 il
va jouer un plan avec plus tard cavaillé
à trois cahiers ces deux donc on va
pouvoir voir vouloir jouer des plans
comme ça voilà alors qu'est ce qui
change pour fne 7 pour les noirs c'est
qu'ils vont vouloir peut-être envisager
de jouer pour ces micro lamente un jeu
rapide sur la colonne c'est les voilà en
effet un jeu rapide ouart connaissait
qu'une possibilité fouet deux câbles et
j'ai eu 7
alors comprenez ce coup un cavalier ou 7
c'est pour aller en la m5
alors pour aller avec senghor sy et noir
jouent maintenant par contre cavaliers
h6 au oui bon c'est une autre
possibilité
c'est en faisant souffler un petit peu
quand même assez pour aller en fait
c'est pour aller au fcc pour les
enseignements même façon mais ça ne
s'est pas tout à fait la même chose
comme c'est pas tout à fait pareil
comment on peut envisager de faire
[ __ ] en cavalier dans ce cas là c'est
possible c'est pau c'est une possibilité
voilà mais il faut savoir que c'est
s'est jamais clair c'est jamais clair on
dirait que c'est pas beau pour les noirs
mais en fait il faut savoir dans ce
genre de variantes supra h christian
prat schiste les noirs omettre le fou
angers7
dans un château comme si le pire est à
côté d'avoir réussi un joli petit rock
et f6 mais là la disparition du fou de
cases noires peut être problématique
pour les blancs sur donc malgré
la mauvaise apparences du coquillage si
c'est un coût qui est jouable aussi vous
prend aussi c'est un pari audacieux mais
intéressant parce que le roi désolant
sécurité pour les noirs donc à noter
alors qu'ammann j'ai eu cette voie là
hélas non s'allier à trois car je sais
qu'on peut juste dire stéphane que sur
une prise dans ses 5
oui parce que le pionner oui alors bien
sûr bien sûr si les blancs prennent ans
et 5 serait sur une grosse faute
bah disons que ce serait parce que le
pion c5 et faibles qui ont aussi
possible scène qu'à alléger si le pion
j'ai eu 5 étant pas tomber de toute
façon même si on le protège est-ce qu'il
va pas être facile et nous ne sait même
pas possible ne peut pas protéger le
crime cinq tout simplement je ne peux
pas rose bonbon mais d'ailleurs la
troupe s'est vraiment pas un bon coup
les rincer les blancs aux sorties emploi
du centre c'est rarement bon coup dans
les côtes dans des cas exceptionnels
alors voilà c'est ça il disait qu'il est
ravalé avoirs à l'étranger olic aiea 3
parce que on peut revenir après l'ours
et prend des claques s'éprend du clac on
y va on va voir on écrira tout de suite
l'idée ses premiers 4 et 4e 5calais ses
deux ferries à une très belle
surprotection là je surprotège macase
des cas donc qui quand même la base de
machinerie pions très important c'est
quoi en fait
la surprotection s'est laissé passer
l'orage en fait on a un point faible
alors d'accord dans les premiers coups
on va peut-être souffrir un petit peu
pour protéger ce point faible mais
enjoint des coûts qui sont pas moches on
est sûr bien sûr les pièces qu'on
développe et tout ça et on s'intéresse à
notre faiblesse
et une fois que tout est d'être solide
et bien on va chasser une à une des
pièces qui nous ont embêtés au début de
la partie avec un effet désastreux pour
le camp qui a va subir cette
surprotection voilà donc il essaie de
leur l'avantagé est sûre protection
informatique peut-être été un peu c'est
que chacune des pièces qui surprotègent
à la liberté de partir je partirai oui
voilà alors mais il y en a qu'une qui
peut partir à la fois mais n'importe
laquelle peut le faire voilà parce que
la surprotection c'est pas la protection
salaires des gens c'est de nager en plus
soit lassé de la protection ça libère
les autres pièces de la de la rente et
de rester là si une 120 s'est passé
après la catastrophe dans sa mine de
rien ça a l'air de on a l'air de
s'enfermer sur la protection d'un point
mais non parce qu'on libère les pièces
et surtout ont pris votre adversaire de
jeu et voilà donc comme l'exprimé in the
beach ou d'un moment notre adversaire
d'un pull perspectives et finit par
n'avoir que des mauvais coups se disent
positionner sur une sorte de ces
exemples au milieu d'un v6 pour les
dragons mise en boîte à questions des
quatre qui vont avoir du mal de rajouter
une pièce à la taxe on voit pas comment
le fouet suite pourrait rajouter de la
pression a lâché 4 et la maintenance g4
seller voilà la surprotection de permet
de déloger
la chaire or se réveille le cavalier le
4e 5 et 4 5 où il peut paraître agressif
c'est un coup en fait seulement
positionnelle c'est bien maintenant on
choisit de travailler et même le petit
rock qui a fait attirant qui a fait
réfléchir officie ne nous inquiète pas
parce que les pièces ne sont pas placés
sur l'aileron oui puis l'euro n'a pas de
problème exactement les pièces noires
sont plutôt à une dame est et le centre
est bloqué le centre est fermé et même
le coup h5 joué ici par vélique et son
adversaire dans cette partie bien sûr eh
bien nous inquiète pas puisqu'on grosses
olives tout simplement avec le coût sera
alors très important jean baptiste ce
coup là jamais se tromper il faut pas
jouer des coups comme et g5 évidemment
un an son horreur visant le cavaliere
revient voilà le cavaly reviendrait à
f/5 l'idée de se coucher 4 c'est bien de
contrôler 5 / h 5
voilà niger sont incarnés ni j'ai pas le
rush exactement donc il faut absolument
garder le contrôle on a joué gkd pour
priver que les deux cas d'absence d'un
acteur important la hache projet 4 je
prends le cas de mes sept tours ici
évidemment elle est menaçante un tout
petit peu quand même sur le roi blanc
mais ya pas de pièce à la taxe est
quasiment impossible le centre est
bloquée comment la dame pourrait venir
attaquer ici est même allé pas le cas
échéant pourrait jouer simplement roger
ii et éventuellement tourache un échange
et sept tours ce ministère y'a pas grand
danger mais il n'y a pas danger mais il
faut faire attention au moins de l'ordre
ne le prenez pas pour argent comptant
regardez avant de le faire comme
monsieur mais dans ce cas de figure où
il était clair s'il ya que la tour qui
la taxent c'est pas du tout un problème
exactement m6 de l'acca de la part de la
part de nora une autre possibilité pour
les noirs ici donc ça aussi c'est normal
il faut réagir au centre talent arrive
est ce que les blanches de g4 il faut
quand même essayer de comprendre comment
les morts peuvent exploiter
et oui parce que là maintenant les
blancs si on laisse sur lui et se faire
ils vont
un jour très facile maintenant il suffit
de finir le développement et puis de
jouer à trois des quatre éventuellement
être 45.2 chose comme 3 et 4 et ensuite
on va sortir ce cavalier on va chasser
peut-être le cas et c'est 6 voilà aux
portes de l'espace pendant toutes mes
scénarios à prendre de l'espace et on va
acculer les noirs font rien jana en
soirée avec les noirs voilà sachant que
les noirs ne sont pas reliés comme un
local si c'est quand même un petit peu
risqué maintenant alors une possibilité
pourrait voir se jouer le coup à fond
5 voilà pour essayer d'attaquer le pion
les planches de 4 voilà on attaque le
protection la protection des caves à une
idée si les blancs prennent évident je
prends des cavaliers la jauge entre mon
père est fort probable et la strophe
puisque l'on peut plus déloger ce
cavalier qui devient énorme
donc il faut surtout pas donc il a un
très fort ce coup puisque si les noms et
les blancs eux mêmes prennent un f6
après j'ai problème si ce qui est la
belle colonie et maintenant qui s'ouvre
alors là c'est un désastre aussi parce
que le grand roque la suite pour les
noirs avec une grosse attaque
qu'est-ce qui reste qu'une solution
alors là on applique un petit peu ce que
tu as vu tout à l'heure c'est à dire la
surprotection ce qui est bien c'est
qu'on peut quand même enlevé une pièce
de l'entente s'aggrave pas pour qu'on
joue cavalier g51j s'en aille parce que
ouattara kg 5 est dramatiquement
affaibli et le grand roque est
impossible à cause de la fourchette
fourchette arrive c'est taylor si les
noirs prennent angers 4 avait dit oui
mais attention je vais venir ici mais
non là ça commence à devenir un peu
embêtant pour le plan réussisse après
vous prend vous prend et maintenant
pression sur la faiblesse c'est l'énorme
dont on est faiblesse d'autant plus que
f4 f5 peut venir et voter blanc il
serait peut aller très vite
ouais voilà l'idée même alors 3 avant
tout la meilleure attaque est bon alors
autre option pour les noirs ici c'est de
jouer le coup et 6 voilà dans ce cas là
on prend pas toujours en et fils
évidemment c'est ses rares moments dont
on a géré la colonne gérant force le
contrôle du centre pour les noirs et
puis on nous la colonne j'ai donc voilà
c'est rarement longtemps le gland
interdit donc tous les trois mois la
voilà ça c'est un coup tranquille il
faut des trois jean baptiste qui vise
les cases blanches
oui alors c'est aussi pour laisser la
casa la dame et ça laisse la case ici
pour la dame deux ans qui va de viser
sur la colonne et la droite collège
fort intéressante pour les dames si elle
se trouve en relais
bien sûr donc là les noirs eux mêmes la
ne prennent pas en règle aussi s'ils
prennent si prenez en scène tout
simplement on poursuivrait pas qu'avec
la baliste quant aux cinq menace des
cavaliers prend 17 qui supprime la
protection de la faiblesse par exemple
le coût calais c'était possible à moi
même laissé lecavalier en le 5 est une
bonne option bien sûr car il prend le 5d
prochain les pré-enseignes des provinces
5 et la niaque à willis et 6,6 à ces
pièces il a angers dame de meules et on
protège protège voilà qu'une position
incertaine mais quand même très agréable
à jouer
on a du fou et 3 qui arrive on est des
fous et 3 n'a pas peur de dalles promet
de tout faire on peut le faire
éventuellement si vous voulez quoi une
fois que les noirs ont fait grand comme
ça on aura les pelles colonnes sur la
langue rock et surtout que là où il ya
encore un jeu qui est assez plaisant
même rangée de f4 peut être envisageable
attention cases blanches quand même le
français 6 peu désagréable tu peux être
migrés le pion f de sa case
bon il ya pas mal de ne pas le possible
est intéressant possibilités
intéressantes fou des trois grands rock
grand roque
voilà maintenant qu'on à l'adresse c'est
un peu comme d'habitude à l'adresse du
roi maintenant le roi et là ça y est on
sait où il est donc on peut y aller
des quatre on a eu peur de sacrifier en
sacrifiant le cube et cap puisqu'il peut
être pris par le cavalier c6 mais ça
serait une erreur tout simplement à
cause du simple tour b1 de toute façon
tu vas tomber et le cavalier cloué sur
la dame et si on le protège avec à 5
tout simplement à 3 est terminée fallait
une pièce et des quatre billets déjà
menace quoi menace de jouer à 5 à 4 à 5
pc terrain en savane et voilà ça va
aller très très vite
alors là les noirs ont une façon de
réagir peut être qui est intéressante a
voulu vous faire papier cavaliers prend
des câbles a maintenant te prendre en d4
alors pourquoi parce qu'une fois qu'il
ya une reprise en d4 et c'est ce qui
s'est passé on voit plus d'être regardé
car il s'éprend des 4 et bien f prend le
5.5 donc là on va récupérer la pièce
puisque le cavalier des cartes
s'attaquer on pourra jouer ensuite aux
quatre alors qui fait à la salle ar bon
pour les blancs les noirs ça à première
vue ça a l'air bon mais si on regarde de
plus près on regarde dame
le coup je vais pas me voilà maintenant
ça veut dire prendre si tu veux dès que
tu prends joseph 4 est en droit et
croise alors voilà scipion prend des
quatre dans ce cas là le simple et très
beau fou et 4 et regardez regardez la
puissance de secours puisque le roi ici
la look et on voit le plan b 4 et le
flou avec cas qui collabore à 716,6 pour
venir bloguer manas tour c'est un échec
dans la partie tout va bien donc bon on
a senti un peu compliqué on a simplement
voulu vous montrer un exemple ce qui est
le plus intéressant dans cette partie
stéphane c'est le principe initial de
surprotection voilà voilà exactement
c'est sur cette île cette manoeuvre
qu'on a vu le fou décède le fou s'est
vite des noirs est enfermé notre
principal point faible c'est le plan des
quatre dans un premier temps tâcher de
le défendre de surprotéger est
naturellement vos pièces retrouvons bien
placé après ce que vous pouvez chasser
les pièces noires qui dans un premier
temps ont montré une belle activité
c'est vrai mais ça n'a pas suffi
pour prendre l'aventage et on peut les
refouler après facilement alors le
thématiques aussi g4 à noter toujours
c'est très souvent dans la française est
menacée notamment g4 à bien doser 1 à
bien nous nous effet le petit rock
attention il pas que c'est bon en toute
situation
c'est quand même un coût qui est
thématique et puis plein de plein de
belles idées qu'on a vu on a vu le camp
bin leurs maris par exemple avec le
sacrifice de planck est une autre option
pour le genre d'attaqué éventuellement
voilà plein plein de petites variantes
thématiques dans cette phase d'avant
j'espère que vous aurez bientôt réparé 3
3 3 grandes notions effectivement ce
second beef ou des trois sources d'un v6
cours à 3 de surprotection à troyes b 4
et cavalia trois cavaliers ces deux cas
il ya trois qualifiés du petit archipel
des classiques on va choisir enfin un
euro son style souvent son style c'est
dans ses variantes là donc c'est une
variante riche la française d'avant ce
qui est quand même donc dans un fonds
positionner le fort à cause de ces
structures de brio et un briquet au sens
donc et quand même pas facile à gérer à
28 et au début où elle vient de dire m
mais avec beaucoup de ressources
tactique aussi bien avec des ressources
l'addition qui par leur présence n'a
porté vers l'avant
on espère qu'avec les noirs aussi vous
aurez pu choisir l'orientation que vous
souhaitez parce qu'il ya pas mal de
choses intéressantes vous avez vu oui
nous ont désigné avec island mais
clément sera peut-être des idées pour
tous ept cette française bien sûr et
puis on essaiera peut-être dans les
autres leçons de présenter d'autres
variantes parce que c'est une défense
qui est très riche
voilà tout à fait mais écoutez on vous
remercie pour d'avoir suivi cette cette
leçon sur la française de davance voilà
le rebord enrageant m'a dit